[Musique]
d'un côté à un sentier ombragé qui fait
le tour du mont royal
de l'autre le bitume d'un grand
stationnement derrière l'un des anciens
pavillons du royal victoria
c'est ce genre de rupture que montréal
veut voir disparaître dans le futur
aménagement
aujourd'hui c'est très agressif en fête
aujourd'hui ses potes se trouve ailleurs
est un set public qui a été laissé il y
a deux projets en inde
mais guy il prévoit d'agrandir son
campus sur la moitié des bâtiments les
plus anciens en rouge sur ce plan et
ceux qui sont plus à l'écart en blanc
reste propriété de l'aes cuit la société
québécoise des infrastructures bouffon
l'accès à la montagne
héritage montréal se réjouit que la
ville
imagine un lieu réellement invitant pour
les citoyens ou le plan qui sera soumis
à une consultation publique prévoit de
faire passer le taux de verdissement de
49 à 70 % actuellement est un site qui
est fort minéralisée on a environ
en fait on est au bas mot 1200 espaces
de stationnement sur les sept donc
beaucoup de d'alpha taz beaucoup de deux
roues c'est donc ce qu'on veut c'est
réduire au maximum comme ce vaste
stationnement qui est peu ou pas
utilisés à flanc de montagne ici est
juste à côté au pied du mont royal il y
à cette piscine nichée dans cet écrin de
verdure qui est inutilisé depuis 2013 un
secret bien gardé à l'époque et qui
pourrait devenir un symbole du nouveau
site
quand on regarde les besoins du quartier
ces 15 mois thérapeutique de penser
qu'on peut avoir accès à une piscine à
des lieux plus vert
une sorte de retour aux sources quand
les bâtisseurs d'origine écossaise ont
édifié l'hôpital à la fin du 19e siècle
écossais de l'époque les grands châteaux
en montagne très roman c'est qu'avec
beaucoup d'arbres donc il y avait sept
samuel à pied on retournera à l'avenir
des bâtiments n'est pas encore décidée
mais le plan directeur propose certaines
balises c'est que les usages comme
l'hôtel soit complètement interdit les
usages comme le résidentiel privé que ce
soit locatif que ce soit condominiums
extra ne serait pas non plus permis
parce qu'on le sait ce que ça donne en
quand on privatise un bâtiment on vient
qu'à privatiser une partie de l'espace
on pourrait avoir de la recherche sont
prêts à voir des entre l'économique et
en lien avec la santé le développement
de la santé des démolitions sont aussi
envisagées parmi les constructions les
plus récentes afin d'abaisser la hauteur
de certains bâtiments essentiel du
projet c'est pour l'instant l'ouverture
comme l'agrandissement du mont royal
mais ce set l'oeil est exceptionnel
ici mathieu prost radio canada
[Musique]